go
sh say hello was that illegal no yeah no
sir uh the roots are stopping us well
because the wind intent violation I
believe my blue lights at you to let you
know who I was yes sir well we didn't
know with it you know that's not a
government tag that is a unofficial tag
that Tag's not even on file I said yes
well we have to catch up the building
from running everything like that sir so
so I won't blink my blue mess at you
next time I'll let you just sit there I
was just thinking I'm gonna please see
for example well nice to meet you Matt
Pope worked for me your Chief worked for
me yes sir there's no need to get upset
I'm upset because I spoke to you when I
come by and now you're pulling me I've
never met your damn mind I understand
that
easy I don't I don't have to talk to you
okay I'm not talking to you
y'all are y'all gonna write me a ticket
are you gonna write me sir we'll just
try it I'm the police
what are you stopping for I'm sorry
okay you know how many uh officers
have blue lights are you writing me a
ticket yes or no
oh you write me a ticket I miss the lady
literally
to make it I'm fixing to make it a whole
lot more
your boss 11 11. I'm out here of
Illinois
machine construction company out of
losersville registration showing as far
as valid insurance
okay
you let her do her job
black color the machine Construction
Company
on a loser's
it doesn't come back to that vehicle
[Music]
there's no vehicle found negative 99.
yeah
what she's about bringing your driver's
license back up yeah uh first when we
ran the tag came back to like a Dodge
Ram so we're just confirming right now
yes sir it's a ghost tag yes
sir yeah we're just you must have run it
wrong you must have run it wrong because
you didn't want to come back
so so it's still coming back to a Dodge
Ram now sir can I ask why yourself is it
still coming back to a Dodge Ram no we
got it fixed why are you so upset no you
didn't fix it dude is it still come back
to a Dodge Ram right now no it came back
not on five that's right because you run
it wrong sir somebody run it wrong
either you did or they did we're about
to get the information okay I got your
teeth on the phone right now that's fine
that's fine that's fine can you calm
down for us please I appreciate your
service I appreciate your service all
right I'm just saying I spoke to you
guys I didn't have to do that I could
have eased on by y'all I appreciate the
job y'all out here doing I'm trying to
be respectful I understand that I
understand I'm not raising my voice
right I understand all right
the only thing I've done wrong was spoke
y'all never would have pulled me over if
I had to flick my blue license no sir no
we were going to pull your s
I'm not gonna lie to you I'm telling you
straight up okay okay but like I said
you know there's people out here in
person police officer with blue lights
she threw my license if she is getting
them for me she'll bring it to you okay
well that's fine I'm just trying to get
through it I'm trying to talk with you I
don't want to talk anymore about it all
righty
yes very professional
whole time